Elijah is with us in Raleigh North
Carolina
hi Elijah how are you hey Dave I'm doing
better than that is there how about you
just the same sir how can I help
hey so I'm I'm 19 and I'm a pretty
pretty new guy when it comes to personal
finance and stuff I've got a clean slate
and I'm about to take Financial Peace
University I'm really excited about that
and the reason I'm contacting is because
since I'm young a lot of people are
heavily advertising the idea of getting
a credit card to me and they're saying a
bunch of stuff like you know giving
money back
I mean percentage of your money back and
all that whatnot and the biggest thing
is the credit score and that if I don't
have a credit score I'm not able to do
anything and I'm pretty sure you don't
like credit cards and you seem to be
doing pretty fine so what you got what's
your what's your advice okay well the
long answer is take Financial Peace
University and you'll get a full
detailed explanation there but basically
you have to decide this okay um you need
to look at wealthy people and figure out
what wealthy people are doing because
they are wealthy in terms of money you
don't want to copy if you want to get in
really good physical condition and you
hire a personal trainer and your
personal trainer is 450 pounds that's a
problem right yeah so you don't ask fat
people how to get in shape right well I
came to you huh and you don't have broke
people what to do with money because if
you do what broke people said to do with
money you know what you're gonna be
broke people right - 70 % of Americans
live paycheck to paycheck
7 out of 10 houses on the street that
these people are talking to you from
have too much month left at the end of
the money they look good they drive a
car they can't afford they go on
vacations that they can't afford and
they put their stupid fake life on
Facebook for everybody just
that's not real it's not real it's a
facade it's all borrowed money they buy
stuff they can't afford with money that
they don't have to impress people that
they don't even really like and then
they give a 19 year old guy like you
advice to go get in debt
so let's think about the credit card for
a minute you said you can't do anything
without a credit score well no that
wouldn't be true what you can't do
without a credit score is borrow money
quickly and easily you won't be able to
go in debt quickly and easily if you
don't have a credit score the only thing
a credit score is used for is to go into
debt the only way you get a credit score
is going into debt so the more you go
into the better your going into debt
score is going to be and the more debt
you could get into because you've
forgotten into debt in the past it's
kind of like a dog chasing its tail you
ever seen one of those oh yeah yeah so
if you're going to pay cash for things
which is what wealthy people do because
they have figured out that their number
one method for building wealth is not
giving their income to other people your
number one wealth building tool is your
income and when you give it to other
people in the form of car payments and
student loans and credit card payments
and house payments and everything else
payments payments payments payments
payments payments payments when you give
everybody else all your income you have
no money to build wealth with thus you
become middle class or lower class
because everything you make goes out to
the bank and they have big tall
buildings with nicer furniture than the
people that give them the money
think about expense so I'm gonna figure
out what rich people are doing and do it
and they don't borrow money is what rich
people do because that they figured out
that their most powerful wealth building
- and if you're not gonna borrow money
you know what your need for a credit
score just went away all right well I
like the idea of that what are some what
are some I guess problems I wants it
probably the situations I could run into
without a credit score why is why do
people say it's necessary so much I
guess well you can't borrow
money so if you want to buy a car you
have to save up the money and pay for
the car you want to go on vacation and
say what the money and pay for the
vacation if you're going to buy stuff
for Christmas you're gonna save up the
money and pay for Christmas if you go to
rent an apartment some people will want
to look at a credit score other people
will rent to you without a credit score
if you go to do some things you know
yeah you know but here's the irony of
that okay I'm a multimillionaire
the building that I'm sitting in this
paid for just this one piece of real
estate that I own is worth seventeen
million dollars just this one building
and now on a bunch of the real estate so
I can go down the street down here where
they require a credit score to rent an
apartment and they won't rent me an
apartment I can write a check and buy
the complex but they won't rip me an
apartment that's how stupid but parts of
our culture have become and so you just
get you know the problems you're gonna
run into is you're gonna run into stupid
but people like that who you just don't
get to participate in their game oh well
I can't rent an apartment at that place
if they require credit score cuz I don't
have a credit score my credit score zero
it's indeterminable
because I'm gonna borrow money in
decades and so I'm just walking around
having to pay for stuff oh darn it's my
only shot as far as getting money back
on your credit card if you get 1% back
on your Discover card that means if you
spend $100,000 on your Discover card
they will give you $1,000 how is that a
path to wealth you're gonna spend a
hundred thousand dollars so that they
give you a thousand that's gonna make
you rich how yeah it's not so it's
stupid the whole thing is just stupid
it's a rigged game to make the bank's
rich Visa and MasterCard is a multi
billion dollar transaction billions and
billions of dollars transacted every
year and then we wonder why people are
broke that's why so I mean you can do
whatever you want to do but you called
to ask my opinion on that and I have to
debit cards that's all I have of a debit
card on my personal account a debit card
on my business account I travel more
than the two of you listening put
together
and I go anywhere I want to go do
anything I want to do sharing I spent
three weeks in Europe this summer we
don't have a credit card we checked into
the finest hotels and ate at the finest
restaurants and have the finest times
you can have and we paid cash for all of
it using a debit card and never had
anybody one time say oh we can't take
you into our five-star world-class
restaurant because you have a debit card
never once did they deny us access you
can do anything you want to do but you
know there's a couple little things here
where you're doing with stupid people
that you're gonna have a problem so the
rule of thumb is listen to wealthy
people do what wealthy people do if you
want to be wealthy people this is the
Dave Ramsey show hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
you
[Applause]
[Music]